باحد اسواق الحبوب في سلا المدينه الشقيقه
للعاصمه المغربيه الرباط تمتلئ اكياس
الحبوب بالقمح لكن ليست الامور على ما هي
عليها
فارتفاع درجه الحراره وتكاليف السلع
كالوقود والاسمده يعني ان العديد من
المزارعين يكافحون لينتاج هذه المحاصيل
الاقتصاديا
بالنسبه للمصاريف طلعت على الذوق في
الهكتار
الاسمده الادويه
الغازوال الفلاح ولا شويه من هذه الناحيه
اما بالنسبه للباحثين ما عندنا ما نقولوا
بانهم
ممتازه بالفعل
لعونه الفلاح تقول وزاره الفلاحه والصيد
البحري والتنميه القرويه والغابات ان
الجفاف العام الماضي ادى الى خفض محصول
الحبوب في البلاد بنحو 70% ولمواجهه هذا
الوضع تسعى السلطات الى العمل على تعزيز
سلاسل للانتاج من خلال دعم اسعار البذور
والاسمده لخفض تكاليف الانتاج وتشجيع
زراعه النباتات القادره على التاقلم مع
ظروف المناخيه وهذا
طورنا اصنافا من القمح والشعير اكثر
مقاومه وتحملا من الاصناف التقليديه فعلى
سبيل المثال في عام الجفاف تظهر هذه
الاصناف محصولا محسنا بنسبه 30 في المئه
مقارنه بالاصناف الاخرى القديمه لذلك مع
هذا التحسين نعتقد اننا يمكن ان نواجه هذا
التحدي ونعزز الامن الغذائي
منذ عام 2004 يعمل المركز الدولي للبحوث
الزراعيه في المناطق الجافه مع المعهد
الوطني المغربي للبحث الزراعي لتطوير
اصناف اكثر مرونه من المحاصيل الاساسيه
مثل القمح يهجن العلماء البذور التقليديه
باصناف جديده انتاجها لتصبح اكثر مقاومه
الامراض والجفاف يقول والقيمون على هذا
المشروع في المغرب ان تحسين مرونه
البحاصيل امر حيوي لقدرتها على انتاج
القمح الهدف ديالنا هو هذا الاصناف في
تارها التعاون توصل لعند المزارع المغربي
في اقرب وقت وباش نقول لكم بان يعطي واحد
الاهميه لتكسير البذور بدينا واحد
البرنامج جديد ثلاثه سنوات فيما يخص تكتير
البذور واحنا حاليا ان شاء الله
نتمنى ولا اربعه سنوات
العلماء على تهجين النباتات باستخدام
التقنيات الزراعه التقليديه لمواصله انتاج
اصناف جديده ويقولون انه من المهم
لاستمرار في محاوله تحسين المحاصيل لان
مسببات الامراض تتكيف باستمرار في عام
2016 قدم العلماء احدث بذورهم الى فهرس
البذور الوطني للحكومه المغربيه
وافقت الحكومه حتى الان على انتاج اصناف
جديده من القمح تسمى نشيد وجواهر وجبل يضم
بنك البذور هذا في الرباط 216 الف صنفن
بينها مجموعه كبيره من الشعير والحمص
والفول والعدس